Yes, because there was a chapel there.
And for whatever reason, the chapel captivated
us.
I think because the building, if I remember,
was round.
There were no statues which, coming from St.
Mary's in Cambridge, you had statues everywhere.
So it was just kind of an odd place to go.
We did find out where the cafeteria was, and
sometimes we could go in and get free sandwiches,
depending on who was working the cafeteria.
As kids we would wander through these buildings,
and as I walked down the corridor to come
to this room that's the memory I have of MIT.
Those buildings with all the concrete walls
and all the pipes in the ceiling, that's how
I thought of it for many, many years.
Very strongly built buildings, like a fortress.
But for us, we were kids.
MIT was just like some other place.
We'd find places to play stickball and tag
football.
As long as you didn't get kicked out by security
that's kind of what you did.
One time we were actually allowed to go and
they taught us fencing.
So as young kids we were able to put on the
mask and use the swords and do some fencing
too, which I thought was great.
No, I used to like the smells in there.
The chemicals and you'd go down the hallways
and you'd smell the different chemicals, and
the other place was the welding.
They used to make all different objects.
I used to like to stick my head in there and
see them welding.
I used to go and look at the ships.
They had some model ships when you went through
one of the side doors, and we'd always go
and look at the model ships.
I don't know if they were built by people
from MIT, but we'd look at the ships.
And oh, just walking up those steps and turning
around and looking back across the campus.
You felt important.